Hello friends I wanted to quickly share
with you a new History Channel I made
called the history Zone this is where I
upload historical videos that fall
outside of the 1800s but I might put a
few 1800s videos up there as well so
take a look when you get a chance now
Wyatt Earp has been a mysterious figure
in history there is not much
documentation on them there are no
videos of them speaking no audio
recordings and so the following video
that you're about to see where the
famous movie director John Ford speaks
about knowing Wyatt Earp is what I
believe to be the only video where
anybody who actually knew the legendary
Lawman in real life speaks about it and
if any of you out there know of any
video or audio of anybody else who knew
Wyatt Earp and talks about it please let
us know in the comments but I do believe
that at this time this is the only one
that exists so let's go ahead and get to
it the day of the recording is sometime
in 1970 or 1971.
you remember the gunfight in the OK
crowd in clementine surely I'd seen it a
couple of times I mean the other other
versions how did you uh come to Stage it
the way you did had you heard
himself tell the story yeah as I've told
you you know we're reminisced about this
many times when why the
retires a law man Henry as you know he
went to some little town north of
Pasadena
now his wife was a very devout religious
woman
and a couple of times a year she'd go to
these religious conventions in Utah
and Eastern Arizona
and right to get on the streetcar I grew
up to Universal City and join us
we became quite friendly
and I didn't know anything about the
okay Corral at the time
but Harry carried you about it and he
asked Wyatt and Wyatt described the
fight fully
exactly the way that you did it
as a matter of fact he drew it out on
paper a sketch of the entire thing and
that's a Wyatt said I was not a good
shot I lived close to a man
and that's exactly what you did
[Music]
thank you